See you
again My cute brain says I'm not getting
enough sleep Ever since then I've been having trouble dreaming
Witha's mother and sister It's
not Kana-chan today I'm going to intervene I
'm not with my friends today
I went to study at Charming Core
a  It's an error, isn't
it? I won't go with you to your sister's bus terminal
[music]
8 me
Diane I saw your sister on TV when I was Chitose.
It's pointless if I go out into society as early as possible,
but hey
, it might look like I'm going to shake it, but even so, I need a
lot of strength to do anything.
There was a trader My sister knew Indian poker
.
And
if you take a route, you might put it in your file like this Plex monsters are the same as heroes I'm sure it's
a short-term personality and it's not strict, but it's a habit of pan-syncing and appealing People
who flirt with men Wait a minute, what did you say with the help of a robot?
It's all fine weather Oh,
I've arrived at the bus stop Ah
Mikoto Onee-chan, you've noticed 4, okay?